pas
où
moi j'avais dit dès bravo par des
acclamations ces mots couteau mais
recommencer parce que c'est pas
désagréable tous demain malaisie bonsoir
bastidon la deuxième émission de
taratata vous savez la télévision c'est
un peu comme le parachutisme à la
deuxième fois on a un peu plus peur car
la première le culot vous a un peu
tomber et on se trouve presque un peu
peureux en face des caméras et pourtant
je ne devrais pas dire ça puisque c'est
un peu moi qui suis l'ossature de cette
émission qui vais vous présenter tout au
cours de la soirée ses vedettes que nous
avons sélectionnés avec soin mais tout
d'abord j'ai omis la semaine dernière de
vous présenter ma partenaire
je voudrais que nous fassions plus
amplement connaissance avec elle ce soir
et sous une fanfare que va nous donner m
tenir à l'eau nous allons accueillir
maintenant evelyne pagès
evelyne pagès qui a fait un effort qui
sait tricoter une robe depuis la semaine
dernière
je dois dire ou alors c'est une façon
agréable utilise it et d'utiliser des
vieux restant de rideau mais en tout cas
c'est ravissant et je vous trouve fortes
à l'aise ce soir un peu plus détendu par
contre que la semaine verdi et bien
voilà ça ce n'était pas répéter ça vient
du coeur
vous savez ce qu'il ya de plus difficile
disait petitjean c'est le comment
souvent ce qui est plus difficile quand
on commence une émission de variétés et
bien c'est quand même de la débuté il ya
plusieurs façons de présenter une
émission de variétés pour ne mécontenter
personne cette fois ci nous allons vous
présenter diverses façons de présenter
une émission de variétés tout d'abord
l'émission de variétés populaires
salut mes lames à s'allumer demoiselle
salut messieurs et parfois je commence
l'émission par la mise à
attention evelyne evry est ce que vous
êtes la reine
non c'est dommage parce qu'on vous a
rappelé eveline maginot
c'est peut-être un peu trop peut-être
et puis c'est jeudi c'est le jour des
enfants il ne faut pas les choquer et
dans le fond on passe trop rarement à
eux à la télévision alors si vous le
voulez bien
présentons les missions comme si on
s'adressait à des enfants présentation
enfantine
mme liu c'est un joli téléspectateurs
les fonctions grouillot il s'était
endormi pendant génial on comme il était
content à salé bouger il y avait plein
de chansons qu'il allait comprendre
parce que les paroles c'est à sa porte
et sarah c'est tout à fait pour les
calaisiens 17e puis après il allait
avoir encore une grosse émission sur la
folie des gammes au public oui tiens
j'ai l'impression qu'il a fait quelque
chose mais je ne peux pas le dire non
plus toute façon cela ne conviendrait
pas parce que il ya peut-être des
enfants il ya peut-être des jeunes mais
il ya quand même quelque chose de plus
étonnant il ya les super jeune c'est à
dire les jeunes alors ça on va le
présenter comme
eh bien ça lui les choses vachement
content de vous voir aussi nombreux ce
soir et je crois que ça va chauffer que
ça m'a balancé terrible je voudrais
savoir si si les filles sont contentes
de ce qu'il va se passer
alors vous savez qui on aura ce soir les
filles
il savait que si on aura ce soir les
garçons alors c'est les filles crient
plus fort que les garçons une fois les
filles
monsieur le curé tout seul bon d'accord
et bien pour faire plaisir aux copains
pour que ça chauffe ça vit ça va
balancer terrible puisque je vais vous
donner la composition de leur pièce à la
batterie works pixon au saxby cats clown
qui avait joué dans la formation de bac
spyros à la contrebasse eric gales
gagnent ce qui fait partie du quartette
de sparkster heinz les violons à la
formation karine xam ce qui accompagne
un copain me tanoh qui chauffe terrible
david alexandre winter